meet louisa she leads a team of
insurance adjusters working directly
with customers after an incident
luisa needs to improve the efficiency
and accuracy of her team's claims
processing
and quickly deliver accurate settlements
so customers can feel taken care of and
continue to place their trust in her
company
however her current processing system is
manual
it's time-consuming and lacks visibility
which leads to lengthy weights
frustrated customers
and even potential fraud she needs a
smart way to integrate multiple systems
to streamline the process automate tasks
and keep track of every claim as it
moves through the system
how can she do it with ibm cloud packs
the ai powered hybrid cloud software is
built on red hat openshift
so luisa can manage applications across
any environment
on-premises on all clouds and on the
edge through one
intelligent control plane with ibm cloud
packs
luisa can have a better view of how and
where her team can help customers
quickly accurately and securely
with the power of ai she and her team
can generate prediction models about
what happened
analyze incident images and ultimately
resolve claims
a lot faster the result delighted
customers
a successful team and a confident louisa
reinvent how you work and re-imagine the
future
with ibm cloud packs